[Música]
momento de hablar de economía aquí en
France 24 en directo América ya nos
acompaña en el estudio Daniel hablandon
bienvenida Muchas gracias Rosa Daniela
empezamos con la expectativa que hay en
Estados Unidos por la decisión de la
reserva Federal sobre los tipos de
interés es una expectativa que mes a mes
nos tiene con los ojos puestos en esta
decisión porque en el transcurso de este
miércoles se va a conocer El veredicto
del Banco Central de Estados Unidos
sobre las tasas de interés y los
analistas le apuestan esta vez a que
esquivara un nuevo aumento después de
alrededor de un año consecutivo de su
vida
Bueno hay un poco de optimismo de que la
inflación resultó ser casi la mitad de
lo que era exactamente hace un año
Entonces el optimismo radica en que
estamos en el camino correcto para
vencer la inflación y en que la Fed
probablemente hará una pausa en las
tasas de interés que es más o menos lo
que han dicho que van a hacer de todos
modos
Daniela y le pregunto hasta el momento
ha funcionado este aumento de las tasas
de interés para reducir la inflación
pues Rosa parece que sí por lo menos si
analizamos las cifras y comparamos las
tasas de interés versus la inflación
vemos como el año pasado las tasas de
interés estaban en un Rango de entre 0 y
0,25% han venido subiendo agresivamente
a medida que la inflación alcanzó un
punto máximo en en verano del año pasado
el 9,2% anual y ha venido reduciéndose
pues a medida que la Fed ha incrementado
sus tasas hasta un nivel que hoy se
encuentra entre el 5% y el
5,25%. de todas maneras Esto no es
suficiente para que los analistas del
mercado no estén pensando que la Fed va
a seguir subiendo sus tipos de interés a
partir de Julio que aproximadamente lo
podría hacer unas dos veces más antes de
que culmine el 2023 bueno seguro que
usted nos lo explica cuando pase Daniela
así es y le digo la agencia
Internacional de la energía ha puesto
una fecha para el momento en que
podríamos reducir el consumo de petróleo
cuándo sería esto pues su Rosa el
consumo de petróleo recordemos tuvo un
fuerte frenazo en pandemia de alrededor
del 10% con casi todos los aviones en
tierra la gente trabajando desde casa al
mundo consume al día aproximadamente
unos 100 millones de barriles en ese
momento se estaban consumiendo 90
millones de barriles un poco más o un
poco menos después vino la recuperación
y con ella el impulso a la demanda sobre
todo cuando china comenzó a relajar sus
medidas de covid-19 pero ese empujón
terminará este año según la agencia
internacional de energía perdón el 2024
yo me estaba adelantando de año la
organización cree que una economía en
desaceleración y la transición a
combustible es más limpios van a socavar
el crecimiento de la demanda de
hidrocarburos a partir del próximo año y
cree también que en 2026 se va a
alcanzar el pico para el caso del
transporte Y desde ahí comenzará a bajar
la agencia fue más inclusive no reiteró
propiamente un consejo que había dado en
2021 de que no se deberían financiar
nuevos proyectos de combustibles fósiles
pero se aseguró que las inversiones
actuales superan lo que se necesitaría
en un mundo que se está encaminando
hacia cero emisiones netas Bueno pues a
ver si es verdad Esta esta previsión no
Daniela sí porque tampoco Es una
transición que sea fácil de hacer no
claramente le propongo cambiar de tema
porque en Reino Unido Parece que la
economía mejora bueno esta economía es
hoy la más reacia hacia la recuperación
entre las grandes del mundo sin embargo
los datos más recientes están mostrando
que el pib el producto interno bruto en
abril creció 0,2% frente a marzo esto
según el gobierno se dio gracias a las
ventas minoristas y a la industria
cinematográfica Aunque sigue siendo el
país con el alza de precios más
pronunciada en Europa occidental y se
espera que lo siga haciendo por lo menos
este año
el ministro de finanzas de ese país
al igual que otros países tenemos un
problema con la inflación es más alta de
lo que la gente esperaba Y si queremos
crecimiento Si queremos prosperidad Si
queremos quitarnos esa preocupación que
tienen las familias sobre el aumento de
la compra semanal Entonces tenemos que
enfrentar la inflación
no hay alternativa para abordarla con
todo el vigor que se necesita Y eso es
lo que haremos
y otro otro tema que nos tiene muy
pendientes es la gira de Úrsula fondan
presidenta de la comisión europea por
América Latina que se sabe pues Rosa ya
dijimos acá que estuvo en Brasil se
reunió con el presidente de ese país
ahora el turno del martes fue para
Argentina allí reiteró que está muy
confiada en que antes de que finalice
este año va a ser ratificado el acuerdo
del bloque comunitario con mercosur que
se negoció durante 20 años y que está
Atrapado desde 2019 en el parla europeo
ese pacto reduciría los aranceles
aduaneros y facilitaría el acceso de los
exportadores agropecuarios sudamericanos
hacia Europa así como el de los
fabricantes europeos a los países del
bloque que son Argentina Uruguay
Paraguay y Brasil
Espero que podamos conseguir que el
acuerdo mercosur Unión Europea cruce la
línea de meta hemos intercambiado una
primera carta estamos esperando una
respuesta y tenemos muchas ganas de
trabajar al máximo para que concluyamos
este acuerdo como un acuerdo beneficioso
para todos lo antes posible
Daniela y el universo Harry Potter abre
su segundo parque temático es rosa le
pregunto si usted es fan de esta
franquicia cinematográfica que cumple 22
años este año no estaría entre los más
fans pero me gustaron mucho las
películas pero sí podría tomar su varita
mágica ponerse su túnica Y sumergirse en
este mundo mágico en el nuevo estudio
que se va a inaugurar el próximo viernes
en que es la capital japonesa le
interesa de todas maneras saber cuánto
cuesta o no por supuesto supongo que el
precio será mágico también No el precio
va a ser mágico las entradas para
adultos cuestan lo equivalente a 50 Ah
no
45,03 dólares Bueno es más barato que ir
a Disney en Orlando por supuesto pero no
se ha abierto el parque y ya se agotaron
hasta agosto Esa es la mala noticia
ahora ya existe una instalación similar
en Londres desde 2012 le ha ido bastante
bien y por eso deciden irse a Japón pero
este trae cosas nuevas que las veremos a
continuación
hemos agregado varios escenarios nuevos
que no están disponibles en Londres por
ejemplo tenemos la escalera móvil de
mármol tenemos el Ministerio de magia de
Londres solo por mencionar dos de ellos
y además de eso estamos incluyendo más
elementos interactivos para que Los
visitantes puedan realmente acercarse a
la magia de hacer películas y
experimentarlas por sí mismos
Daniela bueno cerremos con la cifra del
día un billón de dólares esta fue la
capitalización bursátil que alcanzó el
martes en Wall Street El fabricante de
procesadores nvidia capitalización
bursátil recordemos es el precio de las
acciones multiplicado por el número de
acciones o sea eso vale en el mercado en
este precio los inversionistas o en esta
empresa los inversionistas han
depositado su confianza por su potencial
de ser el gran beneficiario del auge de
la Inteligencia artificial con esto Este
paso la convierte en la séptima empresa
estadounidense que se une a este selecto
club de un billón de dólares en el que
también están o han estado en su momento
Apple Amazon alphabet que es la matriz
de Google Microsoft tesla y meta que es
la matriz de Facebook Daniela pues
muchas gracias por esta Crónica nos
vemos en una hora en una hora de traigo
noticias sobre la comisión Europea y la
Inteligencia artificial las esperamos